Aristide rontini choreographer and performer
Italy
Aristide is a man in his forties he
wears glasses and a black T-shirt
with large white letters his
disability consists in having
his left arm as long as the elbow
Aristide is interviewed in a
Rococo theater and his interview is presented
along with video clips of
dance performances that Aristi di choreographed clips
of Aristide himself dancing on stage
and clips of Aristide moving in a
dance workshop
[Music
] My name is aristiderontini I am a
performer and choreographer in Italy with
disabilities
[Music  ]
as a choreographer and artist I am very
intrigued by how a show can
influence the public's perception
of a theme that is being investigated at that
moment I think that dance
is certainly an instrument of pleasure
and of sharing a
bodily experience but I also think that  have the
ability to shake things up and then
definitions the words and then give
comp  lexity and fluidity very
rigid definition and with very rigid outlines
So to this power to fluidify and
connect my working method which is not yet
well defined But I see
self observing I see that when there is
a need with respect to a theme I like it
I feel the need to nurture
this theme, broaden it, understand it,
understand it from several points of view and it is
purely a job of comparing
people or reading
and therefore searching for information that
helps me understand how that thing
is seen and how I  I'm looking at how
to be able to present it again under another
guise so there's all a
fairly conceptual work of
theoretical research and then afterwards there's the moment of
the meeting room and which narrows
the field of possibilities
in meeting with the performers
lately  I have to say in the last few
projects I have always left more space for the
performer to connect even
individually with respect to the theme by proposing
very simple practices  that give
freedom and going to gradually tighten
the last project I completed is
called litakumi and staves relationship
between man and nature
as ideas also
shape our actions and
guide our relationship with
nature what I liked  a lot of
this show
in the creation was the work with
video projections objects dancers and
throwing ourselves into this of having created a
scenario where performers were able to
experiment playing connecting with the
theme and see what came out in
a very short time which was also
quite stressful though  which in the end
has almost at an institutional level has
come
up with solutions both from the perspective
of the dancers and from my perspective
in which I recognized a lot so
this In the end I have to say it was a
project that got me very excited
[Applause]
[Music]
for me the thing that most intrigues me
in this work is starting from
something  very familiar and starting to
touch the edges of the unknown and then
seeing how these two polarities
meet in the show is always a
discovery that sometimes destabilizes
me sometimes makes me contract totally unexpected things.
So I believe that even
when I watch a show the  i create i
am inside a creation as a performer i
think this is the most
nourishing aspect in our work
[Music]